you think you just fell out of a coconut
tree what
in the context
yeah
she's great I am I'm telling you right
now I can't explain to people how big of
a fan I've become of her as of late this
new Alzheimer's
ant thing she's got like early stage
dementia and things she's got going on
where she's like you young people think
you fell out of a coconut tree but what
you actually are
is you're here and it's like the
craziest thing like I think at this
point that's what I would do because all
of these problems really are so
unsolvable I think maybe that's what I
would do if people are like what are we
gonna do by the border I'm like my
mother used to say to me you think you
backed up into a cactus but that's your
ass talking you know people like what
are you what are these colloquialisms
these strange sayings